debemos hablar más sobre el momento de
inercia ya que es algo que muchas veces
confunde a las personas primero
recuerden que ese momento de inercia
simplemente es la inercia rotacional en
otras palabras que tanta resistencia va
a poner algo que se esté acelerando
angular mente ya sea que se incremente
su rotación o se disminuya si este
sistema tiene un gran momento de inercia
va a ser muy difícil que esto comience a
rotar pero si el momento de inercia es
pequeño debe ser relativamente fácil
hacer que esta cosa se acelere angular
mente y es para lo que sirve este número
el momento de inercia nos va a permitir
conocer qué tan difícil va a ser
acelerar algo angular mente y recuerden
que esto aparece en la versión angular
de la segunda ley de newton esa es la
aceleración angular que va a ser igual
al torque neto dividido entre el momento
de inercia o la inercia rotacional ya
que ambos son lo mismo y esto tiene
sentido estamos dividiendo entre el
momento de inercia ya que significa que
si esta inercia rotacional es grande
vean que como está en el denominador si
tenemos un denominador grande vamos a
obtener un valor pequeño lo que quiere
decir que está alfa va a ser pequeña
será una aceleración angular pequeña
pero si este momento de inercia fuera
pequeña pues va a ser más fácil de rotar
y obtendremos una mayor aceleración
angular ya que ahora estamos dividiendo
entre un número más pequeño por lo que
tiene el mismo propósito en la fórmula
de la segunda ley de newton es el
término de la inercia pero para la
aceleración angular y vimos cómo
determinar el momento de inercia para
una masa puntual y aquí normalmente se
menciona mucho esto por masa puntual me
refiero a algo que podemos tratar como
si toda la masa de ese algo estuviera
rotando a la misma distancia del centro
o del eje y es lo que pasa aquí si
tenemos una bola pesada conectada a una
cuerda que es una cuerda bastante ligera
y que tiene poca masa podemos ignorar la
masa de aquí y si toda la masa estuviera
rotando con el mismo radio como tenemos
aquí la vez pasada determinamos que el
momento de inercia de una masa puntual
que va alrededor de un círculo es igual
a la masa y a qué tan lejos se encuentra
esta masa del eje al cuadrado este es el
término para una masa puntual que va en
un círculo así obtenemos un momento de
inercia que tan difícil va a ser
acelerar la angular mente esa es la
inercia rotacional m por r al cuadrado
pero podemos tener problemas más
complicados por ejemplo qué pasa si no
tenemos una sola masa puntual sino tres
esto también lo vimos la última vez si
tenemos varias masas puntuales todo lo
que tenemos que hacer es decir bueno
para múltiples masas puntuales
simplemente vamos a sumar las
contribuciones de cada una de estas
masas puntuales individualmente
matemáticamente hay que tener cuidado ya
que aquí hay que ponerles un sub índice
a esta masa y a este radio pero no se
asusten esto simplemente significa que
hay que sumarlas todas esto será m 1 x r
1 al cuadrado tomamos la primer masa y
la multiplicamos por su distancia al eje
al cuadrado más m2 por r 2 al cuadrado
es esta masa 2 por su distancia hacia el
eje al cuadrado y a esto le sumamos m3
por r 3 al cuadrado y si tuviéramos más
masas pues sumamos todas las masas que
tengamos si tuviéramos muchísimas más
puntuales que podemos tratar como si
todas las masas se estuvieran rotando a
la misma distancia del eje ustedes
podrían decirme a ver un momento
cada una de estas masas no está a la
misma distancia del eje
cada una tiene una distancia diferente
pero si una masa en particular por
ejemplo m uno está rotando con el mismo
radio del eje entonces podemos usar esta
fórmula para las masas individuales y
las sumamos y el resultado de la suma de
todas estas contribuciones base
la inercia rotacional total digamos que
para este ejemplo la inercia rotacional
total para este sistema de masas va a
ser m 1 por su distancia al eje al
cuadrado es al cuadrado
digamos que b es la longitud de esta
parte de la cuerda y de forma similar se
representa solamente esta longitud de la
cuerda y vamos a suponer que el radio de
estas masas es muy pequeño
aquí las dibujo grandes para que podamos
verlas pero es más fácil si consideramos
que son pequeños por lo que no tenemos
que tomar en cuenta su propio radio y
las vamos a sumar esta m 1 x al cuadrado
es la contribución a la inercia
rotacional de esta primera masa de aquí
es la contribución al momento de inercia
de esta masa de aquí y tenemos que
calcular las contribuciones de cada una
de estas masas por lo que le vamos a
sumar esta masa 2 más su distancia al
eje y no va a ser sólo b va a ser toda
esta distancia de acá a más b al
cuadrado y la contribución de m3
va a ser esta m3 más la distancia a su
eje a b c
todo esto al cuadrado esto va a ser el
momento de inercia total para todo el
sistema lo que va a ser más difícil ya
que conforme vamos agregando más masa a
un sistema más difícil va a ser
acelerarlo angular mente y cómo podemos
hacer que este sistema de tres masas sea
más fácil de rotar
digamos que estamos cansados de
necesitar tanto torque para mover esto
una cosa que podemos hacer es tomar
nuestras masas y moverlas hacia el eje
es decir mover estas masas al centro ya
que si lo hacemos noten que todas estas
erres van a ser más pequeñas y si son
más pequeñas pues tendremos un menor
momento de inercia o inercia rotacional
por lo que va a ser más fácil rotar este
objeto más fácil de acelerar angular
mente la vamos a rotar más fácilmente si
hacemos que todas las masas se vayan
hacia el centro esto tiene sentido
imagínense un bate de béisbol imagínense
a que aquí lo tenemos aunque no es
el mejor dibujo de un bate de béisbol si
lo giramos a partir de este eje va a ser
más difícil de rotar ya que tenemos toda
esta masa pesada en este otro extremo
pero si lo giramos teniendo el eje aquí
lo volteamos y lo giramos desde este
extremo va a ser más fácil ya que casi
toda la masa va a estar en el eje y si
lo hacemos así el radio de esa masa va a
ser menor y si el radio es menor va a
contribuir menos al momento de inercia y
si hay menos inercia rotacional va a ser
más fácil de girar y es bastante más
fácil mover el bate de béisbol si lo
tomamos desde este extremo más ancho al
menos comparado con el del otro eje
donde se supone que debemos tomar el bat
para moverlo podemos moverlo más rápido
aunque no es buena idea porque hace
difícil que le demos a la pelota con
esto pero lo podríamos mover más
fácilmente ya que el momento de inercia
va a ser más pequeño y otra cosa que
podemos hacer es
disminuir la masa si hacemos menor la
masa también vamos a reducir el momento
de inercia y si movemos las masas hacia
el eje vamos a reducir la r que también
nos va a ocasionar una menor inercia
rotacional pero qué pasa si no tenemos
masas puntuales en muchas ocasiones
vamos a encontrarnos que no hay muchas
masas puntuales
rotando qué tal si tenemos algo como
esto que es como una barra que tiene la
masa distribuida uniformemente a todo su
largo y que toda la barra rota en un
círculo ya no podemos usar esta fórmula
ya que es solamente para masas puntuales
porque suponemos ya que para usar esta
fórmula suponemos que toda la masa se
encuentra en el mismo radio pero para
esta barra solo la masa que se encuentra
al extremo final de la barra es la que
está rotando con este radio que será la
longitud completa de la barra la masa
que se encuentra más cerca del eje
tendrá un radio menor y sólo estará
rotando una parte de la longitud puede
un radio de entre 2 y esta parte de acá
quizás tenga un radio de l entre 8 así
que la inercia rotacional total ya que
no podemos decir que toda la masa de
esta barra se encuentra rotando en el
mismo radio si esta barra tiene una masa
total m y una longitud total l no
podemos decir que el momento de inercia
de esta barra sea de m por l al cuadrado
esto no es así ya que no toda la masa de
esta barra se encuentra en el extremo
que tiene un radio de longitud l sólo
aquella partecita que se encuentra hasta
el otro extremo de la barra es la que
estará rotando con una r de longitud l
el resto de la masa va a tener que su
contribución al momento de inercia va a
disminuir debido al hecho de que estas
masas se están acercando cada vez más al
eje así que qué hacemos bueno sabemos
que no podemos usar esto vamos a
quitarla
es que tenemos que usar cálculo para
poder encontrar la fórmula para estos
objetos continuos lo cual es bastante
divertido pueden realizar integrales y
encontrar estos momentos de inercia y
ese es uno de los cálculos que más me
gustan ya que se parece mucho a los
rompecabezas pero si no conocen de
cálculo eso les va a sonar como brujería
y yo les sugiero que aprendan algo de
cálculo e intenten encontrar estas
fórmulas ya que es bastante divertido
pero aquí pues vamos a ver los
resultados y resulta que el momento de
inercia de esta barra y sin conocer la
respuesta correcta nosotros podríamos
decir que es será mayor que igual a un
menor que m por l al cuadrado pues
deberíamos decir que esto es menor que m
por l al cuadrado ya que esto sería si
toda la masa se encontrara en este punto
de acá a una distancia l del eje
sólo así sería igual a m por l al
cuadrado si pudiéramos fundir esta barra
y deja
solo una bola y poner esta bola en el
extremo más lejano estaríamos
maximizando su momento de inercia ya que
toda la masa tendría el radio más grande
r pero no tenemos este caso algo de la
masa se encuentra aquí y otra parte de
la masa se encuentra acá una en el / 2
otra en el / 4 y así por lo que todas
estas masas van a tener su contribución
al momento de inercia reducido porque se
van a encontrar con un radio menor
porque se van a encontrar en un radio
menor así que va a hacer esto menor a m
por r al cuadrado que tan menor va a ser
bueno resulta que para una barra va a
ser una tercera parte de m por l al
cuadrado y si ustedes realizan la
integral van a encontrar que de ahí es
de donde sale este un tercio y esto va a
ser para una barra con el eje al final
de la misma barra este es el momento de
inercia para una barra que está rotando
en un eje que se encuentra en uno de sus
extremos pero qué
pasaría si movemos este eje al centro lo
movemos aquí de manera que toda esta
barra esté rotando en un eje en su
centro ustedes creen que el momento de
inercia de esta barra que tiene la misma
masa y la misma longitud que antes pero
que va a estar rotando en su centro
tendrá un momento de inercia mayor que
menor que o igual a el momento de
inercia que tenía cuando estaba el eje
en uno de los extremos bueno yo me
pregunto esto en donde se encuentra la
mayor parte de la masa más cercana o más
lejana del eje de rotación ya que
sabemos que si podemos decrementar esta
r vamos a decrementar el momento de
inercia y en este caso si decrementar
las erres ya queden se cuenta que las
masas que se van a encontrar más lejos
estarán a una distancia que no es más
grande que l entre 2 l entre 2 de este
lado y el entre 2 de este otro lado
mientras que antes lo que teníamos era
una parte de la masa estaba a una
distancia de l
por lo que sería l al cuadrado pero aquí
ya no es así nuestro máximo será el
entre 2 al cuadrado y por lo tanto nos
va a disminuir el momento de inercia ya
que una mayor cantidad de la masa se va
a encontrar más cercana al eje de
rotación cuando lo tenemos al centro
esto va a ser menor que un tercio de m
por l al cuadrado y si hacemos la
integral nos va a quedar 1 entre 12 m
por l al cuadrado y esto es para una
barra con eje en el centro que otra
geometría común ahí vamos a quitar esto
pues otro caso que es muy común es el
del cilindro a veces también llamado
disco digamos que tenemos un cilindro
sólido de masa m y con un radio r que
será igual en este momento de inercia
bueno ahora podemos decir que no va a
ser igual al momento total de inercia de
una masa puntual y podemos decir eso ya
que no toda la masa va a estar rotando
lejos d
el eje de rotación de este cilindro así
que va a ser menor que esto que de tanto
menor bueno si hacemos la integral
resulta que vamos a tener un medio m por
el real cuadrado entonces el hecho de
que no toda la masa se encuentre a una
distancia r del centro de rotación va a
ser que esto sea igual a un medio por m
por r al cuadrado la masa total del
cilindro por el radio total de este
cilindro al cuadrado y esto es para un
cilindro con el eje a través del centro
por lo que el centro va a estar rotando
justo aquí va a rotar alrededor de este
punto de acá y esto es importante de
notar no podemos decir simplemente a
bueno si es una barra ese será su
momento de inercia
tenemos que saber en dónde se encuentra
el eje de rotación si alguien le dice a
ver cuál es el momento de inercia de
esto sin decirles dónde está el eje
ustedes no le van a poder dar la
respuesta a menos que les diga en dónde
se encuentra ese eje en donde quieren
que ese objeto esté rotando
rota en un extremo entonces va a ser un
tercio de m por l al cuadrado pero si la
barra está rotando en su centro su
momento de inercia será un doceavo m por
l al cuadrado y nuevamente la razón de
esto es que al rotar en diferentes ejes
tendremos que algo de la masa va a estar
rotando con una r diferente al menos en
comparación con algún otro eje de
rotación así que esto fue para un
cilindro también conocido como disco a
veces también nos encontramos esferas
así que este es otro ejemplo muy común
digamos que tenemos una esfera que
también está rotando alrededor de un eje
como lo hace la tierra alrededor de su
propio eje este eje pasa por su centro y
digamos que también tiene una masa m y
un radio r y nuevamente ya que algo de
esta masa se encuentra más cercano al
eje de rotación por ejemplo vean esta
masa de aquí para éste
ando aquí alrededor de este eje en
cambio la masa que se encuentra más
alejada pues va a estar rotando con un
radio más grande por lo que el momento
de inercia de todo esto va a ser menor
que m por rr al cuadrado que tanto menos
para una esfera que está rotando en un
eje a través de su centro tenemos que el
momento de inercia va a ser dos quintos
m por r al cuadrado esto es para una
esfera con eje a través del centro y en
este punto ustedes me pueden decir a ver
un momento tenemos esferas y cuando
teníamos esferas anteriormente teníamos
m ponerle al cuadrado bueno sí pero esto
era para esferas que tenían toda su masa
rotando a una distancia r del eje
tenemos aquí una esfera y tenemos una
cuerda y vamos a tener que esta esfera
va a estar rotando a alrededor de un
círculo de esta manera si ese es el caso
al que se refieren entonces sí vamos a
usar esta fórmula ya que el total de la
masa va a estar rotando aún
r de distancia del eje pero este no es
el caso
esta es una esfera que está rotando
alrededor de su centro así que si
tenemos una esfera que gira en su lugar
pues no va a ser el mismo caso que este
otro de aquí en el que toda la masa está
girando alrededor de un eje de un eje
fuera de ella misma este sería como la
luna orbitando a la tierra si
quisiéramos conocer el momento de
inercia de la luna rotando alrededor de
la tierra podríamos tratar a la luna
como una masa puntual y usar m por r al
cuadrado pero si estamos hablando de la
tierra rotando en su propio eje no
hablamos de la tierra orbitando
alrededor del sol sino girando solita
sobre su propio eje entonces diremos que
el momento de inercia para esta cantidad
de rotación es dos quintos m por r al
cuadrado en resumen el momento de
inercia o la inercia rotacional nos va a
dar un número que nos indica qué tan
difícil va a ser acelerar angular mente
un objeto
vemos una masa puntual en donde toda la
masa se está moviendo a una misma
distancia r del eje de rotación podemos
usar m por r al cuadrado si tenemos una
colección de masas puntuales vamos a
sumar todas sus m por r al cuadrado si
tenemos una barra rotando en uno de sus
extremos tendremos un tercio de m por l
al cuadrado y si la barra está rotando
en su centro entonces tendremos 1 entre
12 m por l al cuadrado un cilindro
rotando en su centro va a ser un medio m
por r al cuadrado y una esfera rotando
con eje a través de su centro va a ser
dos quintos m por el real cuadrado y el
hecho de que todos estos objetos tengan
su masa distribuida a través de ellos
hacen que el momento de inercia sea
menor que m por r al cuadrado y esto se
debe a que la distribución de la masa de
estos objetos tiene algo de su masa a
una distancia menor de él
comparada con el caso de que toda la
masa se encuentra al extremo así que el
hecho de que tengamos algunas de estas
masas más cercanas al eje en un objeto
uniforme reduce el momento de inercia
total ya que reduce la r y si se llegan
a olvidar de cualquiera de estas
fórmulas muchas veces hay una tabla en
sus libros de texto o las pueden buscar
en línea ahí pueden encontrar los
momentos de inercia de diferentes formas
geométricas dependiendo del eje en donde
están rotando que también tenemos que
tomar en cuenta